les éoliennes vont te tuer nos océans
jouer le jeu du fn et contribué à la
montée du voc isme en europe bon un peu
de sérieux pour une fois j'ai été
missionné avec les éminences monsieur
bidouille le réveillère et le monde en
kart pour parler d'éoliennes en mer par
le débat public sur les éoliennes en mer
de nouvelle aquitaine dans lequel est
envisagé l'éventuelle implantation d'un
voire deux parcs au large d'oléron on va
tous traités un aspect différent de la
chose et pour ma part la question c'est
quelles sont les effets d'un parc éolien
offshore sur l'environnement ça va
causer écologie marine pour mon plus
grand bonheur parce que c'est ma vraie
spécialité et oui je vous ai menti
toutes ces années je suis plus
biologiste que géologue pour respecter
un minimum on enlève pour commencer il
faut d'abord savoir un peu de quoi est
constitué une éolienne une éolienne
c'est ça un ventilateur en guise de tête
un mât en guise de coup et des
fondations pour la maintenir en place le
boulot d'une éolienne c'est de convertir
l'énergie cinétique du vent en énergie
électrique les pales qui sont en général
au nombre de trois formés en rotor qui
va se mettre à tourner sous l'action du
vent oui donc ventilateur mais inversé
un quart ont ralenti d'air au lieu de
l'accélérer à l'intérieur de la nacelle
et sur laquelle est fixée le rotor on
trouve un générateur c'est lui qui
convertit l'énergie mécanique en
électricité il nous reste le mât pour
porter tout ça et le support sur lequel
est fixé le mât support qui en mer a
donné des sueurs froides aux ingénieurs
car c'est pas évident de faire tenir un
truc de 180 mètres de haut en plein
milieu de l'eau la méthode la plus
utilisée est un pieux enfoncés dans le
fond marin en utilisant un bateau
spécial que je ne spoile pas car c'est
dans ma vidéo on peut aussi faire
flotter les éoliennes mais pour
l'instant c'est expérimental ça viendra
mais pas pour tout de suite
l'électricité a ramené à terre via des
câbles électriques en passant par une
sous station c'est une sorte de grosse
multiprise une multiprise bien achalandé
avec des escaliers des toilettes et une
salle de repos ouais on rigole pas avec
les multiprises dans l'éolien sûrement
parce qu'elle sert aussi à convertir les
66 mille volts qui arrivent des
éoliennes en 230 mille volts pour la
ligne qui relie le parc éolien sur terre
ligne qui peut être du courant continu
ou de l'alternative selon les cas et qui
nécessite quelques petits soucis ce
thème que je détaille dans ma vidéo et
une fois sur terre la ligne est raccordé
au réseau via un poste électrique tout
ce qu'il ya de plus banal c'est un poste
électrique quoi je précise que
valenciennes utilise du comic sans ms
dans ces scripts suis désolé il fallait
que ça sorte faites ce que vous voulez
de cette information merci monsieur
vidéo il faisait invite à aller voir sa
vidéo pour laquelle il a même visité un
chantier de parcs éoliens offshore et ça
c'est pas de la classe bon maintenant
qu'on est calée sur le quoi on va
pouvoir attaquer le donc les impacts sur
la vie marine
et on va d'abord se concentrer sur la
première étape la fixation de l'éolienne
sur le font pas c'est peut-être le
moment le plus critique pour
l'environnement à cause du bruit et oui
un chantier c'est rarement silencieux et
pour fixer les éoliennes au fond de
l'eau est une étape de battage qui
consiste à enfoncer ce fameux mono pieux
en frappant à son sommet à l'aide d'un
marteau hydraulique imaginez bien que
c'est pas un méga silencieux autre
solution selon la dureté des fonds
marins on peut aussi fort et le substrat
un peu comme on fore une carie chez le
dentiste et même si c'est moins bruyant
que le battage ça reste une activité
qu'on recommande pas trop trop pendant
des séances de méditation pleine
confiance bref c'est un peu la fête de
la musique pour tous nos petits copains
à nageoires à écailles à palettes
natatoire à aideront à tentacules ou à
coquille évidemment l'ampleur du concert
va dépendre de plein plein de choses le
type de fondations utiliser la technique
pour les mettre en place la nature du
fond marin si on utilise des mesures de
réduction du bruit et tout ça tout ça
mais à en mettre dumas on a déjà mesuré
des niveaux sonores de 235 décibels pour
vous donner une idée un concert tourne
autour des 100 décibels et un avion qui
décolle au ton de 120 décibels bon je
crois que je compare ce qui est pas
comparable parce que là on est sous
l'eau et pas dans leur mais en tout cas
c'est bien au dessus des seuils de perte
d'audition temporaires et permanents
chez les mammifères marins du coup ça
peut engendrer des dommages
physiologiques à plus ou moins long
terme sur nos bêtises faites vous avez
pensé à vos abonnés seul et ça pourrait
même tuer des poissons et sa part donné
mon français mais ça chie localement des
narines
sans parler des mammifères marins qui
ont lui sensible le bruit peut les
rendre sourds à plus ou moins long terme
ou les faire déserter une zone
potentiellement importante pour genre
leur cuisine j'ai par exemple l'histoire
d'un chantier de parc éolien en mer du
nord que les phoques puis sur un
périmètre de 40 km effet 21 tony parker
mis bout-à-bout et dans notre zone
d'étude on a compté une douzaine
d'espèces de mammifères marins
permanente dans le golfe de gascogne du
dauphin du marsouin du globicéphales du
rorqual et du phoque gris et pas qu'un
peu les effectifs des dauphins communs
et des dauphins bleus et blancs ou et
estime à plus de 600 mille individus
dans boeuf de gascogne l'équivalent de
la population de marseille en bande
organisée personne peut les canaliser et
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'une fois les
éoliennes installées le niveau de bruit
associé au fonctionnement normal du parc
est faible une fois les éoliennes lancé
les chercheurs vous jusqu'à maintenant
pas trouvé de différence de comportement
notable chez les mammifères ma quant au
poisson ils n'ont pas observé ni
dommages physiologiques ni réaction
d'évitement simplement le niveau de
bruit pourrait masquer une partie des
communications entre ses pages et mais
ils ont cas à part les plus forts ou
apprendre la langue des signes aussi se
faire pousser des bras accessoires
évidemment il ya encore peu d'études sur
le sujet donc ces sas trop ou pas ça
être quelque chose c'est pas impossible
du tout mais pour le démantèlement et
ben on ne sait pas trop mais dans le
doute on imagine que ça va être le même
bordel car l'installation tel rappel du
concert soumare pour en revenir au
moment de l'installation d'éoliennes il
ya eu quelques parades imaginé pour
limiter cette nuisance sonore par
exemple effaroucher les bestioles en
amont pour les faire fuir avant que
leurs tympans explose comme une voiture
piégée à bagdad faire des pauses dans le
chantier
pour reposer les oreilles marine ou
amortir le bruit a posteriori par
exemple avec des rideaux de bulles oui
des rideaux de bulles ils pensent
imitait des harengs qui pète en générant
des rideaux capable d'atténuer un peu le
bruit sous l'eau de l'ordre de 10 à 20
décibels salaires anecdotique mais c'est
déjà beaucoup parmi les autres pistes on
a l'idée de remplacer le battage dupieux
par une technique de vibre au fonçage
l'utilisation de matériaux tampon ou de
rideau de ballons et les chercheurs
réfléchissent aussi à influer sur
l'angle de réflexion des ondes sonores
pour empêcher qu'elles se propagent sur
de très longues distances je m'explique
quand une onde sonore est émise lors de
la construction d'une éolienne il
s'avère que le front d'onde et réfléchie
quasi parfaitement par le fond marin et
par la surface de l'eau du coup elle est
pensée entre ces deux miroirs et elle
peut parcourir de longues distances
comme ça en étant très peu atténué tout
le voisinage profite du concert l'idée
des chercheurs ce serait de construire
une surface spécial qu'on pose sur l'eau
comme un radeau pour modifier l'angle de
réflexion de londres et qu'elle aille
gentiment s'écraser sur le font sentir
bon en tout cas en ligne étant beaucoup
plus amorti c'est encore à l'état de
projet de recherche mais je trouve ça un
peu cool comme idée autre conséquence du
chantier comme on creuse dans le
sédiment pour y fixer les mâts
d'éoliennes forcément on va remobiliser
le substrat comme les remettre en
suspension des particules dans la
colonne d'eau forcément 2 1 les
bestiaires n'y voit plus grand chose
leur vue ce trouble et la lumière
pénètre moins profondément dans la
colonne d'eau on dit que ça génère un
panache turbide ça fait partie de mes
mots préfère ce panache turbide peut
modifier temporairement les communautés
qu'on observe mais bon a priori ça dure
pas bien longtemps donc pas son corps
sauf que ce petit brouillard local peut
carrément devenir un fog digne des plus
sombres heures de long selon ce que
contiennent ces particules faut savoir
que lors d'une pollution dans l'eau une
partie des polluants comme les métaux
l'eau en profite pour décompter
doucement et se déposer au fond
seulement si on remue tout ça on remet
aussi en suspension les polluants dans
notre cas les sédiments de la zone
envisagées ont l'air de bonne qualité
globalement mais il ya eu quelques
petites contamination passé qui risquent
de revoir le jour si on passe le
substrat au milk shake je pense à une
pollution radioactive au nord liée à
l'exploitation de monazite dans la rade
de la rochelle qui a été arrêtée en 1994
et au sud une pollution au cadmium dans
l'estuaire de l'âge associé aux
industries minières et sidérurgiques du
lot en aval il pour voir assuré
l'organisme qui s'occupe du raccordement
des éoliennes rte a dit qu'il ferait des
études d'impact et des modélisations qui
claque pour essayer de limiter au
maximum ce risque de fog c'est pas du
tout un terme officiel 1 c'est moi qui
l'inventé il faut savoir disrupt et dans
la vie bon assez causer du chantier il
est temps de parler du fonctionnement du
parc éolien offshore et de ses effets
sur l'écosystème marin haut
alors déjà il faut savoir que notre site
d'étude est situé dans un parc naturel
marin et une réserve naturelle nationale
ce qui n'est pas incompatible avec la
présence de parcs éoliens soit dit en
passant est à proximité de neuf zones
natura 2000 trois nefs et 3 ico je ne
suis pas en train de faire un avc un cd
acronyme qui désigne diverses zones
naturelles et protéger tout ça c'est
surtout pour souligner la richesse et
l'importance de ce coin là en matière de
biodiversité donc on va en avoir des
choses à dire
[Musique]
on peut commencer par le plus évident
les oiseaux vous connaissez flop flop la
mouette toutes les espèces ne réagissent
pas pareil face à ces gros ventilateur
incertaine vont déserter complètement le
parc d'autres vont juste slalomer entre
les mains en changeant d'altitude et
d'autres encore sont carrément attirés
par les turbines comme les cormorans
j'ai envie de dire la sélection
naturelle quant aux collisions direct il
est difficile d'estimer le nombre
d'oiseaux qui finissent en carpaccio en
général on considère qu'il est assez bas
dans un parc en mer du nord il a été
estimée à une quinzaine par an et par
turbine en moyenne dont les deux tiers
des espèces migratrices mais je doute
que ce soit transposable à d'autres
situations parce que ça dépend de la
localisation des éoliennes des espèces
d'oiseaux des là vous êtes abonné leur
activité sur la zone ils voleront pas la
même attitude selon site sont de passage
s'ils viennent pour hiverner haut pour
s'alimenter selon s'ils sont rares ou
pas s'ils préfèrent éviter les turbines
ou se précipiter dessus pour leur faire
des câlins enfin tout ça moralité ça
risque de changer la composition des
assemblages d'oiseaux et potentiellement
déplacer certaines espèces qu'on a pu
observer c'est qu'en général quand un
parc éolien s'installer à moins
d'oiseaux après qu'avant toutefois
néanmoins c'est pas forcément dus à la
présence des turbines on va revenir
dessus après en tout cas il s'avère que
le site envisagé pour l'implantation du
parc abrite une communauté importante
d'oiseaux à toutes les périodes du cycle
de vie certaines y viennent pour
nidifier faire pousser leurs marmailles
d'autres s'y arrêtent pendant leur
migration entre l'arctique le nord de
l'europe et le continent africain
d'autres hivernent sur place pour passer
les fêtes au chaud on chercha pas la
patte contrepèterie d'autres encore sont
carrément résidente est il ou leur
petite bicoque à l'année donc gros enjeu
sur cette zone côté côté oiseau mais les
oiseaux ne sont pas les seuls à flirter
avec les rotors des éoliennes non non
non il ya aussi nos copines nocturna les
chauves souris kova des chauves souris
en mer vous dise à 10 pour sûr vous
répondez oui leur arrêt d'aller chasser
à plus de dix kilomètres des côtes ou de
migrer en passant par le même qu'en 2013
un chercheur a trouvé une pipistrelle de
nathusius aux pays-bas jusqu'ici on s'en
fout sauf que batman avait été baguée
trois ans plus tôt au royaume uni et
qu'il avait simplement traverser la mer
du nord depuis alors que vous vous
n'avez pas bouger de votre siège depuis
le début de cette vidéo comment vous
sentez vous bref oui on trouve des
chauves souris en mer mais surtout des
espèces migratrices et uniquement quand
le temps est bon donc ça limite d'autant
le risque avec les éoliennes offshore
comparé aux éoliennes terrestres et tant
mieux parce qu'il leur arrive un truc un
peu fou aux chauves souris parfois jamal
et oui freud non seulement les chiffres
aubeterre peuvent se payer les pales
d'éoliennes de plein fouet mais en plus
si elle passe devant la tête des
éoliennes elles peuvent subir des
différences de pressions qui peuvent
entraîner des hémorragies internes
et sa fraude c'est ce qu'on appelle un
barotraumatisme
merci jamel bref les chercheurs ont
identifié un risque de collision et de
déplacement si les animaux font des
détours pour éviter les turbines ça leur
coûte plus d'énergie donc ça peut avoir
des conséquences sur leur vie c'est
valable pour les chauves souris comme
pour les oiseaux en d'ailleurs imaginer
vous avez l'habitude d'aller travailler
juste à côté de chez vous et du jour au
lendemain parce vous est muté sur le
plateau de saclay autour de l'île
d'oléron donc dans la zone qui nous
intéresse on a identifié vingt espèces
de chauves souris dont 5 sur la frange
littorale ou en mer sachant qu'elles
sont toutes protégées en france
[Musique]
on l'a dit juste avant il ya moins
bronze omar en général dans une zone en
pleine mer quand un parc éolien s'y
installent soit parce que le ballet des
rotors les dérange soit et c'est
l'hypothèse privilégiée par les
chercheurs parce qu'il ya moins bateau
de pêche qui fréquentent les parages et
les oiseaux marins sont des morfales qui
aime suivre les navires pour grignoter
les miettes rejetée par les pêcheurs ce
qui nous amène à un autre effet
d'éoliennes les conflits d'usagé à
l'intérieur d'un parc éolien en général
la plupart des activités de pêche sont
interdites notamment celle qui risque de
ramasser non pas des roll mops mais des
câbles électriques qui relie les
éoliennes donc adieu le chalutage par
exemple du point de vue écologique c'est
plutôt qu'on pour les fonds marins qui
ne subissent plus de grand nettoyage au
karcher régulièrement et qui permettent
donc à l'ensemble des chaînes
alimentaires de vivoter en traitement en
france il doit y avoir des couloirs de
navigation pour que les pêcheurs
puissent quand même dit xavier entre les
éoliennes mais bon ça fait toujours un
terrain sympa pour que les poissons
puissent jouer à chat perché avec leurs
copains en ciré jaune de la même manière
si un parc s'installe ça peut empêcher
d'autres actes et maintenant vous êtes
abonné
tivité socio économique dans la zone
comme l'extraction minière et de
granulats le transport maritime tous à
tous sont là encore c'est moins clair
que ça en france puisque la décision
d'autoriser ou non la navigation au sein
du parc relève du préfet maritime
conséquence de tout ça les bestioles
sont moins dérangés par les humains à
l'un des mamans vous êtes abonné non il
faut pas vous désabonner allez j'arrête
j'arrête là tu
es là vous êtes d'ailleurs des parcs
éoliens offshore les cétacés peuvent
participer à danse avec les stars sans
risquer de se prendre un paquebot dans
le flux en bref la vie est belle pour
tous les compartiments de l'écosystème
marin et même les chercheurs ont
remarqué que les parcs éoliens offshore
ressemblait pas mal aux réserves marines
en fait c'est à dire que les espèces s'y
concentrent et que ça peut avoir des
bénéfices à plus large échelle par
exemple les aires marines protégées
contribuer à renouveler les stocks de
poissons bah oui ils sont tranquilles
ils peuvent se reproduire à gogo et du
coup ça profite aux pêcheurs c'est ce
qu'on appelle les spill over effect les
retombées les effets d'entraînement c
est fait là sont avérées aussi pour les
parcs d'éoliennes offshore et ça marche
pour les poissons les coquillages et
crustacés si vous avez la chanson dans
la tête j'ai réussi ma mission mais
c'était fait réserve n'est pas le seul
avantage de la présence des éoliennes en
mer et moi qui pensais passer toute la
vidéo art aller franchement j'ai été
surprise de trouver des trucs positifs à
dire je m'excuse sincèrement auprès des
pessimistes qui me regardent
[Musique]
donc je disais après les faits réserve
on a aussi les faire récifs qui se met
en place là où on fixe les pièces
d'éoliennes on y coule un socle et on y
met des gros rochers et ben ça c'est
bien c'est génial même parce que ça crée
de l'hétérogénéité dans l'habitat qui
aurait juste été constitué de sable ou
de vaste tout bête il sauf tout le
respect que j'ai pour le sable un bruit
savez bien vous avez déjà vu des images
d'épaves sous marine qui grouillent de
vie et bah ça ça illustre parfaitement
ce qu'on appelle l'effet recife les
bestioles marine ont tendance à se
concentrer là où il ya des obstacles et
les socles des éoliennes joue justement
le rôle de récifs artificiels là en plus
il ya plein de petits recoins se
réfugier bref ça fait le bonheur de
certaines espèces des algues au tourteau
et omar en passant par les bébés mots ce
nouvel habitat profite bien évidemment à
toute la chaîne alimentaire qui dit plus
de coquillages dit plus de poids sont
donc plus de mammifères marins et aussi
d'oiseaux le plus grand bonheur des
pales d'éoliennes la diversité et
l'abondance des espèces stoxx et l'effet
est plutôt rapide puisque on voit la
différence en quelques mois à peine tu
m'étonnes qu'ils se concentrent dans le
coin aussi ils ont un open bar on leur
fout la paix ils auraient tort de s'en
priver c'est un effet très localisés ça
dépasse pas les quelques dizaines de
mètres autour de chaque socle mais
multiplié par le nombre de turbines dans
les 70's dans notre cas si j'ai bien
compris ça fait plein de petits hotspots
de biodiversité sans parler des mâts
d'éoliennes eux mêmes qui sont colonisés
en quantité par des moules on parle de
une à deux tonnes par turbines en mer du
nord quand même des anémones des étoiles
de mer et toutes sortes de bestioles ce
qu'on appelle le biophare les chercheurs
proposent même de se servir de ces mâts
pour faire de l'aquaculture dessus qui
sait peut-être que bientôt les moules
d'éoliennes viendront concurrencer les
moules de bouchot sur nos tables
le revers de la médaille c'est que les
mâts d'éoliennes vont aussi accueillir
des migrants et les migrants vous savez
ce qu'on en pense sur cette chaîne sur
ses mains on va trouver un mélange
d'espèces native et normatives par
exemple une huître japonaise qu'on va
trouver sur des éoliennes aux pays-bas
skis et bob c'est que ces espèces
introduites ont le potentiel de devenir
invasives et de déstabiliser
l'écosystème en classe et souvent des
espèces plus résistantes qui se
reproduisent plus on plus vite que les
espèces locales et qui des fois les
bouches aussi en gros elle leur vole
leur travail enfin leur niche écologique
mais pour en revenir aux bonnes
nouvelles c'est que si ces mâts
d'éoliennes concentre de grandes
quantités de coquillages filtra et de
certaines bactéries algues et crade et
bien ça peut améliorer la qualité de
l'eau et oui c'est le super pouvoir de
certains organismes qui sont très forts
au filtrer l'eau et en extraire les
polluants comme les métaux lourds ils
vont alors craché une-eau-pure com votre
esprit avant d'arriver sur cette chaîne
pour la toute première fois
on appelle la bio remédier a subi et ça
tombe bien parce que dans la zone
envisager les teneurs en métaux lourds
de l'eau sont légèrement supérieurs à la
médiane nationale donc s'il ya moyen de
faire un brin bioremédiation pour faire
baisser ses taux ce n'est pas de refus
[Musique]
autre impact et non des moindres ça va
être technique accrochez vous ça en vaut
la peine on a parlé des câbles
électriques qui relie les éoliennes
entre elles et aux rivages oui le but
c'est pas de faire joli c'est quand même
de générer l'électricité un rêve a donc
tous les câbles électriques qui vont
émettre un champ électromagnétique tout
autour d'eux et ce dans le cas des
éoliennes pause et compose ses câbles
sur le fond ou qu'on les ans ou y mais
encore un mot fétiche après vu que ce
champ électromagnétique est très très
très localisée autour du câble plus loin
on enterre mois il affectera la colonne
d'eau et donc ses habitants alors je
vous vois venir tout de suite vous dites
que ça à faire naître de terribles
créatures marines à trois yeux
ressusciter les mégalos dont les
mosasaures a déjà rien à voir ce que
c'est des rayonnements non ionisants
aller voir ma vidéo sur les ondes si
elle est sortie et sinon bah je vous ai
spoiler sujet de la prochaine vidéo
ensuite il faut savoir que les niveaux
des champs électromagnétiques émis sous
l'eau sont 12 à 100 fois inférieur au
seuil réglementaire fixé sur terre par
la commission internationale des gens
importants qui s'en occupe votre
cafetière ou votre ses cheveux peuvent
générer des champs plus intense que ça
apparemment il n'y a pas des masses
d'études sur le sujet donc difficile de
conclure vraiment sur les effets des
champs électromagnétiques sur les
organismes marins mais déjà ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que tous les animaux ne
sont pas et certains sont plus
susceptibles d'être affectées par ces
câbles sous-marins j'ai nommé les
espèces électro sensibles comme les
anguilles les requins les raies et les
hippies naturopathe ces bestioles sont
doté d'organes spéciaux qu'on appelle
des ampoules de lorenzo qui leur permet
de mieux capter nous très faible champ
électrique autour d'eux au hasard ceux
émis par une propre plan qui est dans le
sédiment par exemple certains requins
vont être attirés par les câbles
électriques et peuvent aller jusqu'à les
mâchouillait et d'autres sont moins cons
que et vont les éviter et d'autre part
on a les espèces qui se servent du champ
magnétique terrestre pour s'orienter
parce que les champs émis par les câbles
vont distordre se signale un peu comme
un aimant qu'on approche d'une boussole
et c'est mal de perturber le google maps
des animaux poisson comme mammifères
marins et en particulier des espèces
migratrices comme le saumon ou
l'anguille même si c'est une déformation
très local et qu'ils ont l'air de s'en
sortir un globalement mais c'est pas
tout ça pourrait aussi affecter d'autres
plus petites bestioles des expériences
en laboratoire suggère que les champs
électromagnétiques pourraient retarder
le développement des embryons chez les
oursins et les poissons notamment donc
ça pourrait affecter la vie marine à la
fois au niveau cellulaire et
comportementales bon après ça a été
observée en labo c'est pas du tout
évident de pouvoir transposer ces
résultats dans la nature et par ailleurs
j'ai aussi trouvé cette étude qui
répertorie les effets mesurés des câbles
sous marins sur différents groupes de
bestioles et ça tempère pas mal ce que
je viens de puisque l'auteur classe c
est fait comme étant minime et se
conçoit un requin une ré une anguille
concombres de mer ou le poisson qui vit
dans son anus pour les tortues et les
mammifères marins il dit qu'on ne sait
pas donc c'est négligeable c'est
peut-être un peu léger pour le coup de
toute façon il est clair qu'il faut
davantage de recherches autour de cette
caste une cession n'en a pas assez il ya
aussi d'autres effets liés à la présence
d'éoliennes offshore notamment comme on
touche au relief sous marin on peut
modifier l'hydrodynamisme locales et
donc la répartition des sédiments ça
c'est pour les géologues qui me
regardent et aussi la pollution chimique
les matériaux utilisés peuvent re
larguer des substances pas jojo dans les
sédiments ou dans l'eau que les
organismes peuvent ensuite boulotter je
pense aux peintures et au protection
anticorrosion d'éoliennes par exemple
tout ça ça peut nous faire une
contamination locale forte en certains
composés notamment en aluminium en
cuivre et en micro plastiques pour finir
et si on causait de l'impact
environnemental des matériaux utilisés
il est temps de dégainer ma carte le
réveil heures salut ballantyne et
bonjour à tous effectivement j'aborde
tout ça et il ya beaucoup à dire puisque
malheureusement il ne suffit pas de
planter une petite graine dans le fond
marin pour que des éoliennes poussent
une éolienne en mer est une grosse
structure qui dépasse la centaine de
mètres et demande surtout beaucoup
d'acier les éoliennes en mer utilise
également d'autres matériaux résine et
fibre de verre ou de carbone pour les
pales cuivre pour les câbles et sujet
polémique un peu de terres rares je
passe plusieurs minutes a détaillé ces
questions de matériaux alors n'hésitez
pas à faire un tour sur ma vidéo aussi
ce sujet vous intéresse on s'est
démantelée des parcs éoliens en mer et
une éolienne est recyclable à
l'exception des pales qui peuvent être
valorisés de différentes manières il ya
évidemment des émissions de co2 pour la
production la construction et le
démantèlement mais ramené à la quantité
d'électricité produite ces émissions
restent faibles 80 fois moins qu une
centrale au charbon et 30 fois moins
qu'une centrale au gaz
voilà c'était tout pour moi merci
ballantyne et à une prochaine merci
rodolphe aller voir sa vidéo c'est très
important en résumé attention j'ai avoir
des propos très clivant il ya du bon et
du moins bon à l'installation d'un parc
éolien offshore j'avais pris le pire est
un moment de l'installation des mains
après c'est plus ou moins que du bonheur
le zoom concernant les impacts
écologiques il faut garder en tête que
d'une c'est très bien aussi là je vous
ai montré les effets générique
d'éoliennes sur l'environnement en
basant sur des études de parc d'un peu
partout dans le monde ces effets peuvent
ne pas être exactement les mêmes pour le
projet en bassin d'aquitaine et seconde
manche je vous ai parlé que des effets à
court terme on manque encore beaucoup de
recul pour estimer les effets à long
terme les concessions d'éoliennes vont
jusqu'à 30 ans et avec le changement
climatique notamment les espèces qu'on
retrouve aujourd'hui au pied des
éoliennes ne sont pas forcément les
mêmes dans dix vingt ou trente ans donc
potentiellement les impacts non plus et
concernant ses effets à court terme je
suis tombé sur la conclusion d'une étude
qui résume assez bien tout ça et comme
je suis extrêmement flemmarde je me
contentais de vous la lire
les effets s'accumulent et son
conducteur est toujours le résultat de
nombreuses influences soul intensité
variable de ses influences les résultats
de cette étude indiquent que la présence
du parc éolien a conduit à une
augmentation local de la biodiversité a
offert un abri à des organismes
benthiques c'est-à-dire qu'ils vivent
sur les fonds marins et des poissons et
engendrer des légers changements dans
l'usagé que font les oiseaux de la zone
ces effets sont ils positif ou négatif
cela dépend des objectifs écologiques
défini pour cette zone dans les aires
marines protégées qui se focalise sur la
présence de certaines espèces d'oiseaux
bien défini les effets des turbines
peuvent être considéré comme négatif
dans d'autres zones déjà lourdement
impacté par la présence humaine un parc
éolien peut mener à une amélioration de
l'habitat ou même un rétablissement de
l'environnement
et ça c'est pas un élément anodin du
tout parce que les endroits où on
implante des parcs éoliens sont rarement
des écosystèmes christine encore un mot
fétiche en général ils subissent déjà de
fortes pressions dues aux activités
humaines trafic maritime pêche et
pollution par exemple il c'est pareil
pour notre site d'études c'est pour ça
aussi que c'est si difficile d'estimer
l'impact environnemental d'un parc
éolien parce que comment savoir si les
effets qu'on observe son duo park aux
autres activités humaines ou un mélange
de tout ça est plutôt que de se dire
qu'on a un parc là où il y avait rien
avant il faut plutôt envisager sa sous
la forme d'un compromis entre les
différentes activités humaines dans la
zone sous plein d'aspects différents et
dans notre cas lesquels ont un impact
environnemental moindre par rapport à
d'autres à méditer
et là vous êtes abonné en complément de
cette vidéo je vous invite à aller voir
celles du bidouille et de monsieur
réveilleur pour avoir une vision plus
globale de toutes les problématiques
autour des éoliennes en mer vous pouvez
aussi essayer le jeu en ligne créé tout
spécialement pour l'occasion et qui vous
permet de vous mettre dans la peau de la
maire d'une commune littorale qui doit
installer un parc éolien et qui est donc
confronté aux enjeux de terrain de
biodiversité tout ça et puis vous pour
alerter n'en parlant votée concernant ce
projet en bassin d'aquitaine merci
évidemment mais pour buveurs que j'aime
d'amour c'est très important de vous
souteniez la chaîne comme ça autant plus
que j'ai pas eu le cnc et d'ici la
prochaine vidéo je vous invite à aller
voir mes petites pastilles complotistes
que je réalise pour la chaîne info ou
mytho qui est tenu par milan presse ça
va vous plaire
tut tut tut
[Musique]
tut